I'm doing a gig for the head of Sony
Music he just retired really holy
Tommy Mottola mmm wasn't that he was
like I think he was that he was the sigh
he was the head when he married Mariah
Carey when he was the president whoa
whoa this is not gave me material Tommy
was I don't think it's all really no no
it's
he's what if this exposes me is actually
being a rich kid that's my dad still
jokes about being married to Mariah
Carey go sorry I thought you were my
Tommy Mottola he goes really goes that's
the best roast I've ever seen in my life
when I took this gig I thought you were
Tony was homeless I was really only
doing this because I thought I have a
bunch of Mariah Carey that I thought
were gonna know
Martin Martin Bandier chairman and CEO
of sony/atv music forever he's retiring
hey let's take a look at him that's the
picture they sent me that one right the
city guys you guys could you could smell
the money through the picture that is so
much money you don't say the guy
who hides the vaccine for AIDS yeah he
looks like his
[Music]
what I remember very much before I
started doing comedy I think several
years before I even thought of doing it
all my mom's TV in her bedroom
I would watch on Philly 57 uptown comedy
club which is where I saw you and you
and Rob mag naughty what were the were
the white guys with Maceo and Monteria
ivy and all these guys on this show and
it was you got started so many bits
remember the drunk cops yet top cop yeah
yeah with Macy oh you would do and then
it was very cool when I started working
the comic strip when I first got New
York Maceo was like a regular I think
he's like a cruise ship like I think
silly but Maceo was a comic was around
and might seem AG naughty and these guys
I bow to me that registered from uptown
comedy club but I also starting in
Philadelphia just by where it was in the
timing and it's a was after the fall I
guess of several comedy clubs in
Philadelphia and all that remained was
the laugh house which is a black comedy
club and that's where I started I only
did the black comedy circuit for years
like before I ever crossed over into the
mainstream stuff and also knowing that
world when I got to perform at the
Browns place the Uptown Comedy Store
there that was such a cool thing for me
yeah if you well I mean pandering wildly
obscure but doing well still but I I
knew I had a panther nice in the
beginning wow that's quite a throwback
yeah 1992 93 94 did that fee I mean that
had to feel at the motel on were you in
comedy when that popped up I started I
started in 85 mm-hmm but when I say
started it means I started dabbling
right just open mikes occasionally and I
played over I would started a rock club
real college or something no no high
school high school so in high school I
would go to this rock club called
February's on Hempstead Turnpike in
Elmont
okay and it was a row it was a rock club
so me and my friends and and my friend
would say you need to emcee and I would
emcee I'm a first joke was cuz Live Aid
just came out
that's how I remember this and Live Aid
I was looking for an Ozzy joke cuz Ozzy
was on some uh very first joke was did
you guys see live how great was Ozzy you
know you had freddy mercury and and u2
but when they threw the Ethiopian on
stage and Ozzy bit his head off ain't on
his eight people gone and then I was
doing so this place called February's
which was a rock club and they would
play metal and priests and all these
guys and then I went to Governors in
Long Island yeah and I played there
three times and I really thought I was
gonna be discovered immediately that's
how that's how cocky and confident I was
I reached out to managers in a Yellow
Pages about a month in the comedy like
well time to get some muscle
behind the shuttle it's a muscle behind
this muscle - III you know cuz I I
started in the inner age I remember
submitting to like a Sierra Mist
competition and I was like well probably
puck me out of Tucson and it'll be cool
to buy a car a first month but we're
gonna February you're like 16 17 now 17
18 crazy you're like 17 you're
like let's go rip into Governors I was
26 driving out the governor's like I was
I was 19 when I started I was 21 I was
21 and but it took me five wyff's have
not even going on stage before
attempting to go on and if you feel you
felt comfort that people knew you though
- a little bit
no nobody know the show the shows the
rock show and then and then I went into
acting and I got some jobs but then my
family moved to Florida and it me
up threw me way of course yeah and so
1989 I was watching Arsenio Hall and I
said god I want to go back to stand-up
god I want to go
why don't I follow my stand-up career in
1989 I'm watching or was 88 some like
the Arsenio Hall and
Murphy's on there and in our Sidney goes
so uh Eddie this is your young comedians
out there what you got a vice for mm-hmm
and Eddie Murphy looked at the screen he
goes he goes don't listen to your mother
your mother tell you to fall back on
stuff you can never fall back if you
want to be a comedian you do it a
hundred percent if you wanna if you
wanna do something you got to a hundred
percent you kept a twenty percent here
for the presenter went all the she's
talking to me and and so that I saved
all my money yeah in Florida as a waiter
for a year and I said I'm gonna take off
and go full-blown and never look back
and that was 1989 July and I went to a
place called ROM Bennington's comedy
snow yeah at the Radisson in Clearwater
Florida
yeah yeah and then 30 years ago
yeah this and then two and a
half three years later I was I was I was
featuring which means you do 30 minutes
yeah headlining but I should not have
been headlining and then I said I gotta
move to New York LA by way did you get
it I just but not the sidebar here too
much but you get like a nice coked up
whacked out rompe we're all dying to
know what it would be like that was
reformed successful wrong I know smooth
jazz old junkie story I know I want to
hear the yeah I know been doing
like uh you know Fred Astaire
flips awful that's what I want I want
five I've gotten double glasses on the
head I want a guy that's
waitresses are nervous to be alone with
dress like eight AC Slater
Ron Bennington it was called the Ron and
Ron show and it was on like 98 rock and
he was the biggest radio DJ in the Tampa
st. Pete Florida I mean he was huge and
that's literally coming from he just
went on the radio to promote the comics
from the comedy club and they were like
you're pretty great you want to just be
on the show yeah yeah and then so he
only showed up once in a blue moon
and when he showed up yeah it was like
Ronnie Dangerfield shown but danger
feels you inert now I don't I'm going
out tonight is not tight enough I can't
go in front of Ron and he would
go up and you talking about Philadelphia
and he would do his set like robes like
Phillies and the hooter girl
it was huge these girls he was full
blown rocks vanilla yeah extremely
intimidating he's huge
I'm still intimidated oh and that's in
1991 I said I'm moving back to Long
Island in my friends basement and in six
months I got the opt-out economy club
and then so I kind of got shot out of a
cannon quick and at two years on there
and then development that means
Chappelle gonna have a sitcom and then
and then Senate like it all happened
really quick yeah but you moving from
Florida to New York and you know you're
featuring you're doing some headlining
work down there when you move to New
York do you notice that your jokes works
like my jokes work but everyone hated me
okay
who's taking the black Club I'm just
saying like when I moved from Tucson to
New York and I was doing the same thing
I was featuring which was a stretch in
Tucson and I'm seeing and I moved here
and I was like oh I was totally wrong I
like had to do a thing where I was like
tear it all down we got a restart
everything I did - and I hated certain
comics cuz they were such dicks yeah I
hated Marc Maron I hated louis c.k I
hated all these because
they were dicks like snobby they were
snobby you look down on me so my
attitude was like well you I'm
gonna crush you yeah and through time
and and even to tell at one point I will
you you going
stage in you and you insult me when you
go up on so you yeah I'm gonna
crush you
I love and so zero to sixty day a little
so I had I had I came with my feather I
came like hey you guys I'm just
trying to be funny yeah mark and they
all you know Dave we all eventually it
was all cool after a while yeah
mark eventually apologized and I even
mark at one time because Mark was
all about you know I'm not doing TV man
to Kufa TV and all that and so he's like
you you know and and before I would go
onstage he go
Brewery gonna go up room with your
animation and you're not really friends
did why you being a dick I'm just trying
to do my time and then I would do a set
and ANATEL would go up after me he's
like butchered for Breuer and his hand
puppets sorry I'm talking about
dead hookers as intelligent as all you
guys so yeah I had a problem when I
first got here and then loui never gave
me a problem but I just felt like he
just didn't he just looked at me as like
I'm very I try I hope it reads but I
make a concerted effort because I was
helped so much ironically by a Dave
Attell helped me as a bunch of my career
the patrisa
the list goes on and on yeah Bobby Kelly
who helped my career thought I just saw
him in Aruba yeah yeah
but people that have helped me like that
so when I'm on the road and like the
features and hosts I'm always like try
to be very cool too and like I'll take
him to lunch or something just because I
know how much that meant to me
I learned Jay from those days I would
never treat other comics like that
whether I like them or not like them I
would never do that to another comedian
ever
and so now I want to make it clear those
that was the beginning sure yeah the new
comic from water you got shipping your
shoulders from here and you're back to
New York so you're kind of I'll show you
yeah I'm the good-looking gonna be on TV
guy you and your artsy
look at beat Knicks dating is dating is
weird
yeah well because you had comedy I
assumed that wouldn't work well I'm like
the coffee shop and I've never had that
either where I could go to the coffee
shop they're always like there's a very
poopoo e of it but I also realized I
don't need to go there I don't need that
credits not my crowd yeah that's a
pretty important thing for your audience
if I play baseball I as a comedian I
compare myself to baseball player I
don't want to sing or walk
I want the and I and I'm gonna flip the
back yeah Barry Bonds those
are slow around the bases and I I the
pitcher going to try to throw me inside
again stupid yeah that that's it's you
learn ok I only swing it fast balls and
the fastball is I knock in the upper
deck I'm not gonna woo you with my
intelligence I mean I'm not gonna try to
talk over your head that's not me I'm
not that smart I'm good when everybody
should hope everybody should hope that
everyone's not the same kind of thing
well when you're selling the odds that
you're the best at that thing yes are
slim but also being honest with yourself
and like what you want to do there's a
lot of people that be like I want to do
something I see something else is
popular let me do that but if you just
if you do yourself you know you can be
like because that Barry Bonds thing is I
think we all have that you want to
flip the bat in the picture get
as you get older like you get the
novelty of like I get still the
silliness as a comic especially you
tries to write something that that hits
people that you think Jeff Dunham
success and people always you kind of as
a young comic you definitely go uh
because you even with that thing but the
end of the day
well I someone's got to do that things
like no I don't do that thing he does it
probably great yeah
why do I care it's Adam you should
almost be happy it's out of your lane
would show you what you're going for Jay
you hit it and you reach a maturity in
life like there was a time where I hit
in life I went oh my god mark found mark
found himself
yeah he's thought I was a dick and I'm
sorry guy and I'll never forget a tell
one time which Dave would never remember
this I think it was it was right before
I got sound alive and he kind of pulled
me said he would remember that nobody
goes you should be on TV you know what
why he says like your TV guy ma'am
surprise TV hasn't know what the king of
is so I was like oh my god Dave accepted
me and then Louie Louie no but it was
you start seeing everyone else mature
and then you're like you know what there
comes a time to we're not competing
against everyone you just compete
against yourself yeah you set yourself
goals and I'm happy for everyone who
does whatever case you a long time to
get there unless you find very young
success doesn't happen for everybody or
at least like the success where you're
like I'm good and if you find that young
maybe but it really I said that when I
realize that's one interesting things
when I got my our special Comedy Central
the next day one of the first things
that hit me were I was to call Kevin
Hart because I've always had the story
like yeah you know okay went as we lost
touch because he went to Hollywood he
became a huge star and what are you
gonna do but I go I never really worked
hard to stay in touch with him me I
thought of that I was like yeah I didn't
want to hear about how awesome
was going form constantly so yeah I
mean you realize there's a maturity
forget yeah and even a maturity you can
learn how to go like you can actually
learn to be the opposite and have
someone in your life you're like oh I'm
I'm pulling this along I'm you know I
shouldn't let go of this because clearly
I'm the only one that wants this thing
but like you can do that with like
harboring resentment I know you're
getting at and the leasing of porn the
lead singer of corns been to texting me
back late the child Davis
carib he writes back though no everybody
says about Gary Clark and he wrote back
too but no don't give me your number
I'm just bring it up I'm not gonna make
it weird what's in a while a lot of blue
blue like a cool man right even it's
it's kind of cool to hear you say that
because you know as a guy that looks up
to you and a guy like I mean dude the
Pesce show with you and Colin is that's
like one of the things that I remember
clearly where I was when I was watching
it like as a weird 13 year old
just being like this is the funniest
thing I've ever seen in my life and it's
great to hear you say stuff about like
you know Louise being a dick to you and
you're like cuz I have this incessant
need to be liked it's pretty obvious to
talk about a lot on the show
yeah and louis c.k is a god and i got in
at the cellar yeah exactly that's how
you walk around and it was like Louie
Louie didn't dislike me but Louie didn't
like me and for me that was like a thing
where i'm like and i do i suck a my
spine out of controlling you hear
someone else talk about it and it's kind
of like oh okay I'm just and I gotta say
he never was blatantly addicted me yeah
just as much in my head sure yeah in my
head he just didn't like me cuz he
didn't give me the time of day and that
really bothered miss exact same thing in
that Chris run Chris Rock's never spoken
to me in a thousand times he's walked
past me you know what you can feel my
power he understands that I might hate
it you can't feel my bigger and blacker
scum I think it's like it's so
relieving to hear someone else say that
because you you go through it and then
you're like home having shower arguments
with Louie CK really yeah dude
well you jerked off in front of
a liter good dude you're like dude he
did nothing to me and I just but
when you trivialize your own comedy but
it's the same thing there's a thing you
do that's what you makes your comedy
unique you're able to do impressions you
do voices you break that into your
comedy
what he said you think comics like Dave
Attell are like cornball can't live in
that man you're not doing summer tell
you said that's the big deals nothing
for a tell your comedy I had that Maron
moment with Kevin Brennan where I'm
waiting to go up I'm about to go on
stage you know and he goes you gotta
make him laugh with your wrestling
noises and it's just like that's just
Kevin playing with you and I'm just like
right when I learned that then I just
got a bite your nose off old man
and then he's just like laughs yeah he
laughs he texted me while I was on stage
he was following me last week at the
cellar I'm on stage I get offstage just
a text from Kevin Brennan it just says
hack bitter asshole I was just sending
you that to throwing you off when you're
on stuff yeah that's yeah when you
realize that it's not yeah I love Kevin
Brennan yeah like when you realize it's
not right you down a bleach what you
gave already a cow gallon of bleach on
those moments though yeah you just it
but it's like but I'm saying like if jim
brewers on our show being like yeah I
thought I'd mark Mayer and whisper that
to me I'm like oh dude I'm just like
zero to 60 dance it's like barking at
the door like do people know Judah
Friedlander early when I first got to
New York would go at the Boston Comedy
Club
I'm always ago wall leaner yeah I guess
my elbow is up or something he goes god
man goes when you do comedy everyone's
just what we were all in the batches
laughing cuz your hand when you talk
just keeps balancing here's the thing
until like a like three year comic oh
God just my thought was pretty cool is
working the Boston Comedy Club you know
it's funny I got into the Boston comedy
club doing the Sunday night there which
was their black show a talent and will
sylvans talent and and that's where I
want to go will so much yeah that's it
go back but when could you say you came
back to Long Island and your friend's
basement and then months later was on
Uptown comedy club how did what was the
the lead-in to like you getting into the
black circuit of calm
because that show was like it was
because of that I got into that and that
honestly changed my life a many I mean
what would use I was just an audition
you did you weren't doing like black you
won't pull that like a comedy rooms Oh
Oh interesting
no as a matter of fact that changed my
life as far as on so many levels
I grew up in Valley Stream New York
where in Long Island at the end of my
street was the borderline across the
street was all black we were all white
yeah
so if a black guy wha if we went into
the black neighborhood we'd instantly
here go home white boy right and if they
walk down the street by us the entire
neighborhood would stop like a black
bear was walking it was like that white
chicks like no hide me who is this black
bear so it was really intense so I grew
up I'll say racist all I knew was black
people
I thought rape killing murder I'm gonna
get robbed so now your family perpetuate
that they think they was the news it was
the it was the culture sure who guards
the culture and when I got uptown County
club now I'm in Harlem every single and
all I remember was how much it changed
my life and one of the greatest I
learned so much about life I saw a guy
get shot really I'll never forget a
changing moment for me was there was a
couple big changing moments
one was Tracy Morgan was on that show
and Tracy became very close
and I know this sounds crazy but was guy
named Yee and I remember his real name
and he wrote I Eve wrote the top cops
and ye looked at me like one animal
looking at others like yo you push stuff
in your hair no what do you mean like
you got can I touch your hair touch my
hair he's like what what is that that
makes your hair stand fascinated by my
hair and as I can I touch your hair
never touch the back person's hair I'm
being serious
and and I remember being on the street
and I heard and I heard like and it was
on 125th and 5th and Tracy came and he
went who got shot and when you heard
that it was somewhat it was fireworks
you were know so Boyd got shot and I
went woody and he went daddy across the
street I did his down there forget was
like a movie scene I looked across
street and I saw a guy on all fours
struggling for his life and I I went
numb and I'd even pay attention the
traffic I just walked to him and I'll
never forget the image of this guy's
blood just streaming out of his nuts his
head dripping down on the sidewalk going
into the curb and down into the sewer
and people there was a big woman going
look at you now off you stupid
mouth I see I told you I'm like
nobody gives a like what is what is
going on this is so far from anything
I've ever seen
you didn't feel there were cops coming
or anything no and then the paramedics
came and they were like I'm not
exaggerating ever like telling jokes and
and while they're telling jokes to each
other laughs and they're like you're
gonna stay still if you don't stay still
you're gonna be dead I don't tell you
what year is this like 99 this is 92 93
this is right before Giuliani
cleaned this is new you know this is
also right before that there was a cop
killed by the Nation of Islam and I'll
never forget that I was in a bodega and
there was a big Nation of Islam guy
behind me yeah
and he started he started him with me
and I was scared to death he was like
you white devil
what you doing here oh my
god oh my god I'm dead I'm dead and he
had leather and then what's his name
flex the juice - yeah flex said yo man
why don't you get educated you don't
know this kid you don't know this white
boy he's more he's more he's got more
soul than you'll ever have and those two
started going at it and and the nation
Islam guy called him Uncle Tom I was
like what's an Uncle Tom well like what
what lingo is going on here and I
learned so much about life culture how
demographics are held in a position
because wait this is the story of how
you became unrighteous tell me the story
of how you found out flex was an Uncle
Tom I've even remember one day that that
neighborhood loved me so much yeah to
the point where now is parking in the
back streets and they were all late and
what's our white boy what's it and
because they knew you from the show they
knew me from the show that's awesome and
they knew I would I was non-judgment and
I was like I feel so safe here and I
remember going walking the back streets
and and when I was really comfortable
there and they loved me I'll never
forget there was cops chasing a guy down
the street and this guy was running
towards me and I went oh my god I could
take this guy out I could be a hero to
these cops yeah and I also saw the whole
neighborhood just watching and I went if
I take this guy out
they're all gonna turn on me yeah your
snitches and I just went I let him run
and he got caught like 20 feet up the
road but me and me and Tracy had about a
three hour conversation about
black-white welfare drugs why ghettos
exist why our mentality and I and I
swear in my life and my children's lives
to this day I wish the entire world
heard that conversation because it would
have changed so many lives and and one
of the things that really I'll never
forget going back to my neighborhood and
you know cuz you want to fluff your
feathers and I'm on TV and I went to
this bar that I used to go to all the
time and one of the kids from high
school that was a star came up to me
this parts heavy I don't know if I
should say it rollin erupted and he and
this is this is when I realized how much
I changed but how much we're brainwashed
and how much it's it's you just
brainwashed racism is brainwashing and
he goes on both sides not just white
people that's another as for us we
do excel at it though we know we do good
but trust me it's not just us we just
handle we're just smarter about you know
[Laughter]
I swear my life this is a moment that
changed my entire life guy comes up to
you sick man you see you on TV
but he said the word and I went I just
looked at him wet yo it's it's it's not
what you think it no I'm actually
friends with he went anyway you're
friends with that know what yo did and
then I swear I'll never forget he went
he looked at me he got mad at me and he
went oh I get it cuz you get a salary
from them he just couldn't comprehend
his hatred was so powerful hope you try
to explain it to him because honest I
grade but it it I knew right there its
deaf ears yeah and that made me go
like this how do you even begin to
change something - I think there is a
time where it's too late for people I've
added just a smaller scale with just
comedy you people I said trying to
explain to somebody who waits in line of
fans to tell me they thought I sucked
and I should change what I do forces
going like don't you feel like maybe you
just didn't like it and maybe I'm not
you were think like people don't see
that kind of thing you know so it's also
that guy to walk up with a cub sorry
damn but I got to walk up with the
confidence he goes I'm gonna drop a
couple em bombs and go this guy's gonna
be into it like he the thing he knows
that you're from and this go goes this
guy's definitely gonna jump on my
embalmed path here this is this is gonna
work it's like one of those things sorry
but it's like one of those things we
were just talking about where it's
someone else's spilling on you like
this guy's popular in high school he's
watching his life slip away realizing
that high school might have been the
pinnacle right and you're on TV
showing up he's the one thing he's got
on you he's like it let me just be
racist his to try to make him feel
bad that he's but that's but I can
honestly say five years before that that
would have been me yeah I'm not gonna
and I hate when people like who said the
n-word in 1977 oh please so yeah people
grow people learn about life for the
record I still 207 p.m. today they
mature fine if I was judged for things I
did in 1983 1984 85 I I might be in jail
yeah so he's like that that that I don't
know I brought all that but like
comedies one well it's an interesting
thing but it's changed my life it's the
comedy club was the greatest thing ever
happening in my life that's awesome I
grew up in a neighborhood that was
relatively mixed and became blacker as I
got older in it and then I moved to
South Jersey which was really white very
few black people and then when I started
going back to Philly to do comedy it was
the black comedy club and that's sort of
where I landed and started for the first
two or three years it was mostly what I
did was the black comedy circuit and I
mean less than a year in I don't
remember going there like in the
beginning there was places that were
scary there was places where things
happen that were bad and scary but I
didn't go to gigs with that thing always
like
we're going into like there was a rough
room at Manhattan proper like in
Brooklyn maybe like let's the room like
boy if it goes bad for a second but I
kind of always knew also I had the
pander enough to be like I know how to
be the white guy he's black here's a
fight this is so years later okay
years later my wife he gets born again
it's another whole story okay and again
to that story and she has she's getting
involved the local church and whatever
so I said hey uh I get sweets at Shea
Stadium she and she goes do you ever
think you would take them they're all
Cubs fans kids from Wisconsin the past
or not I said want to take him to a Mets
game so we're going to the Mets game
from Jersey and we're in the worst
traffic ever so I get off the Harlem
River Drive and went I'm gonna go
through Harlem because there's no Harlem
so as I'm going through Harlem I have my
kids lives I'm going through and I see
these people like petrified oh this is
the from Wisconsin so they're completely
out of their own way another me and I
swear my life you can't even if you
wrote this in a movie scene they'd go
it's too over the top we're at a red
light and I looked at this guy Sean who
was sitting next to me when Sean I know
you look worried I gotta be honest we if
if the work if it all went down this is
the place I would go cuz it's the place
I would feel the safest I said this
community would welcome me with open
arms and he looked at me and went really
and just as that happen I hear wow
looked and there's there's a guy with
his wife and kid like yeah let me get a
picture
it happened at every red light and it
wasn't like yeah your reference work is
Immaculata hits me every time I don't
know maybe I guess I'm the audience
[Laughter]
[Music]
Nelson Webster this week she's got
questions for you
Murphy from brilliance yeah yeah your
eyes don't deceive you
I do five dollars for a meet-and-greet
guy stop pinching yourself it's him
you're awake me from such scene there oh
for sure you're for sure
to his friend right now he goes aw man
this guy's great day to wear my tightest
sweater over button-down my god god damn
that guy's ass fills those things that I
really I'm jealous of that there's got
case charts so hard to see you he's
almost muscular what are you doing what
are you - what are you doing are we
touch me are we doing tell me I love you
did he seesaw with a fat guy right now
in the courtyard I'm a fee from billions
things to standards how are you welcome
to Midtown he's my tan everybody I wish
you didn't wanna lose we need to jump up
on the chair and like step down at the
back of my head I'll give it a shot you
give it a shot Oh
you don't think I could do it if you
should check up this footage right now
you don't think I'm graceful enough that
I could do that I don't know $5 so you
talk like this for like a whole bevy
fives hours yeah I'm a fee from billions
telling me I can't do a chair wall I'm a
doubter you guys picked a good time to
come down we learned ax cap all right
there Zoey
the move where you sit up upon it and
then so he goes Charlie do Charlie
Chaplin yeah dude
why you trying to bleep me up everybody
from billions is not what you think
we're out of doing regular yeah war
about talk a drink Dunkin Donuts more
about me doing this thing right now
okay I get your stairs out get your
stairs and everybody there he is in the
flesh stop it this is about you I need
you can't do this yeah I definitely not
maybe not in these shoes
maybe not on these shoes the way into
women's huh Jay you know you're the
third nipple you're afraid they're gonna
see me go to the hospital get nervous
when you see three people at the same
time walking together Jay you cry at
cold showers nobody wants me to do it
say what film crew could be more
encouraging she can't wait to get on
WorldStarHipHop they're looking for
content busting your ass they don't want
to see ya wasn't Jay oakerson throw not
do it this is a not thrive situation I
can't do this can I do it I gotta do it
okay okay say this yeah I'll do it okay
on a sweatpants day
huh jerk I agree this might not be the
look yeah
huh what Janet Jackson use wrestling
that she's doing wrestling that Janet
Jackson's whirring rustling man go hey
we gotta go John yes sir it's me jo
Kristin the flesh your favorite I knew
was you I let's go up get this on camera
big Jay oakerson cares
okay this is Dan Soder and big Jay
oakerson from the bonfire on Comedy
Central radio sirius XM 95 come back
next Thursday for a new episode of the
bonfire said the bonfire a lot he said
my name I did dude because I love you